la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y
en a t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès donc adopté
sous les réserves d'usage madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues notre
ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement notre séance
s'est retransmise en direct sur Public
Sénat et notre site internet chacun sera
Atlantique au respect des uns des autres
respects du temps de parole et
immédiatement je donne la parole au
président Hervé Marseille pour le groupe
de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues avec mes
collègues j'ai souhaité attirer votre
attention sur un sujet qui nous
préoccupe gravement
c'est notre relation avec les pays du
Maghreb et en particulier avec le Maroc
cette relation avec un pays historique
et dégradé nous y étions il y a peu avec
le président Combon et une délégation du
groupe d'amitié et nous avons pu mesurer
l'état de dégradation de la relation
entre la France et le Maroc nous sommes
pas reçus par le monde dans les
ministères on est reçu dans les parties
ou à domicile même si ces chaleureux et
donc on voit bien que depuis deux ans
le Maroc qui est un pays ami
historiquement depuis longtemps où nous
avons beaucoup d'intérêts et qui
constitue nos yeux et nos oreilles dans
cette région et bien
est en difficulté dans sa relation avec
la France alors cette relation elle
n'est pas exclusive de ce que nous
pouvons faire de façon équilibrée avec
l'Algérie ça c'est fait pendant
plusieurs années de nombreuses années
nous avons consenti de gros efforts en
direction de l'Algérie président de la
République s'y est rendu peu de temps
après madame la Première ministre vous y
êtes allé avec une grande délégation
force est de constater que c'est
renoncements finalement que nous avons
consenti ont été peu couronnés de succès
si j'en crois les dernières mesures du
gouvernement algérien qui a cru de voir
réintroduire un couplet assez peu amical
en direction de la France dans l'hymne
national
et bien
président de la République a reçu hier
madame Meloni
ce qui existe entre l'Italie ce qui
existe avec le Maroc et l'Algérie c'est
l'Union européenne c'est l'Union
Méditerranéenne pardon et l'Union pour
la Méditerranée est en rade il y a pas
d'autres mots depuis plusieurs années
maintenant depuis longtemps maintenant
et donc il est indispensable que pour
affirmer la place de la France en
Méditerranée pour que nous puissions
engager un dialogue utile sur les
problèmes migratoires et pesés au sein
de l'Union européenne il est
indispensable que nous puissions
relancer cette Union pour la
Méditerranée et que nous puissions
travailler à nouveau dans des conditions
de confiance avec le Maroc parce que les
Marocains sont nos amis au Maghreb donc
madame la Première ministre
quelles initiatives pardon quelle
initiative comptez-vous prendre pour
relancer l'Union pour la Méditerranée et
les relations avec le Maroc
merci
pour vos réponses à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs des sénateurs
monsieur le président Hervé Marseille
la France a une relation très riche une
histoire partagée et des liens humains
particulièrement étroits avec le Maroc
comme avec l'Algérie
une histoire de cette intensité n'est
jamais dépassionnée et je veux le redire
nous avons un objectif clair
développé et approfondir nos liens dans
le respect mutuel avec chacun des deux
pays avec l'Algérie nous continuons à
travailler dans l'esprit de la
déclaration d'Alger pour un partenariat
renouvelé entre la France et l'Algérie
vous l'avez dit je me suis moi-même
rendu à Alger en octobre 2022 quelques
semaines après la visite du président de
la République pour qu'au présider le
Comité intergouvernemental de haut
niveau les deux présidents de la
République échangent de façon très
régulière nous souhaitons aller de
l'avant il y a bien sûr des obstacles
mais surtout il y a une volonté une
volonté commune partagée par le
président Macron et le président teboun
de regarder vers l'avenir et de
construire au bénéfice de nos deux
peuples nous restons bien évidemment
vigilants notamment dans le domaine
migratoire nous avons sur ce sujet
un dialogue exigeant en particulier sur
la réadmission des ressortissants
algériens en situation irrégulière
avec le Maroc nos liens sont très forts
qu'ils soient humains économique ou
culturelles la relation franco-marocaine
ce sont par exemple plus de 46 000
étudiants marocains en France 46
000 élèves dans les établissements
français au Maroc et plus de 1000
filiales d'entreprises françaises la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colonna s'est rendu
au Maroc en décembre dernier pour une
visite très positive le souhait de la
France est de poursuivre
l'approfondissement de ce partenariat
d'exception au service des intérêts que
partage nos deux pays et à la hauteur de
la relation que nous voulons avec le
Maroc et vous avez raison monsieur le
Président Marseille l'avenir de nos
relations avec l'Algérie et le Maroc
comme avec la Tunisie s'inscrit plus
largement dans notre politique pour la
Méditerranée la France est à l'origine
de l'Union pour la Méditerranée elle
continuera à prendre à prendre des
initiatives fortes pour renforcer les
liens entre les deux rives et pour
apporter ensemble des réponses concrètes
à nos défis communs notamment en matière
d'environnement je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Cathy a
poursu poli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
le président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues les assises des finances
publiques que vous attendiez comme un
moment fort de ce quinquennat est en
réalité un nouveau manque rendez-vous
manqué dans votre volonté de considérer
la voix des collectivités territoriales
l'Association des Maires l'Assemblée des
départements des régions de France ont
refusé de participer à cette grande
messe ils ont eu raison selon vous ce
sont de nouveau les collectivités
territoriales qui devront faire des
efforts pour désendetter la France on
parle ici de 10 à 15 milliards d'euros
vous leur demandez de réduire de 0,5
leurs dépenses de fonctionnement alors
qu'elles sont déjà en difficulté les
budgets des collectivités 2023 ont été
construits dans une extrême fragilité et
ceux de 2014 le seront encore plus les
mères les présidents d'agglo les
présidentes communautés de communes nous
explique qu'ils n'ont jamais eu autant
de mal à boucler leur budget aujourd'hui
les municipalités ne disposent même plus
de leviers fiscaux pour assurer des
recettes pérennes suppression de la taxe
d'habitation suivi d'une suppression de
la cave à coups de 49.3 comme si ce
n'était pas suffisant vous augmentez le
point d'indice des fonctionnaires
territoriaux c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais une fois de plus sans aucune
compensation financière de l'État ce
sont les services rendus à la population
et la libre administration des communes
que vous impactez par vos décisions vous
êtes incapable de travailler avec les
collectivités territoriales sur des
sujets qui affectent leur quotidien y
compris de dialoguer avec celles et ceux
qui chaque jour sont sur le terrain je
parle des élus locaux vous leur demandez
d'agir en faveur de la transition
écologique mais vous leur demandez de
dépenser moins que l'inflation chaque
année c'est réduire les chances de
répondre aux enjeux de développement
durable monsieur le ministre quand
allez-vous vous quand allez-vous mettre
en place un réel pacte financier entre
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales afin de garantir le
service public et de prendre en compte
les réalités locales je vous remercie
pour vous répondre
au ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics monsieur Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice Cathy
c'est le Ministre des comptes publics
qui vous répond mais c'est aussi les Luc
local je suis conseiller municipal dans
ma commune depuis près de 10 ans
maintenant et je le dis pourquoi je le
dis parce que ce mandat local me permet
d'avoir une conviction absolue c'est
qu'on ne peut pas opposer l'État et les
collectivités locales que les
collectivités locales ont évidemment
besoin de l'État notamment dans des
périodes de crise pour être accompagnés
que l'État a besoin des collectivités
locales pour que l'investissement se
maintienne un bon niveau dans notre pays
et qu'on a tous besoin les uns des
autres pour relever le grand défi de la
transition écologique qui nécessitera un
investissement public massif raison pour
laquelle nous devons avancer ensemble et
avancer ensemble y compris sur la
maîtrise de nos dépenses publiques parce
que quand nous nous retrouvons dans une
situation de tension sur les finances
publiques que les taux d'intérêts
augmentent c'est un impact évidemment
pour les finances de l'État mais ça
aussi un impact pour les collectivités
local notamment dans leur projet
d'investissement avec des taux
d'intérêts qui augmentent et qui
impactent leurs projets d'investissement
et donc c'est tous ensemble que nous
devons aussi être capables de relever ce
défi celui de garder le contrôle sur nos
finances publiques on avait présenté un
programme de stabilité une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
l'an dernier avec Bruno Le Maire qui
prévoyait un effort sur les cinq ans à
venir supérieur pour les collectivités
locales par rapport à celui de l'État on
a eu un grand nombre de débats ici dans
cette hémicycle on a entendu ce qui
était émis notamment par les sénatrices
et les sénateurs la nouvelle copie du
programme de stabilité que nous avons
présenté prévoit l'inverse un effort
supérieur pour l'État par rapport aux
collectivités locales -08% pour l'État
versus moins 0,5% sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement en volume pour les
collectivités locales ensuite il nous
appartient de construire ensemble les
mécanismes et la manière dont nous avons
nous allons avancer nous avons reçu les
associations d'élus il y a eu trois
réunions encore dans les semaines
récentes au niveau technique nous les
avons su au niveau ministériel nous
allons continuer à avancer avec elle
avec un objectif avancer ensemble au
service du pays et encore une fois des
investissements que nous aurons à faire
pour la transition écologique et une
méthode celle de la confiance je vous
remercie merci la parole est de notre
collègue Dominic Théophile pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre des Outre-mer
monsieur le ministre la Guadeloupe
s'apprête à affronter une hausse du
trafic aérien notamment avec les
vacances estivales s'il s'agit bien
d'une aubaine pour notre territoire
après deux ans de crise covid une
nouvelle difficulté s'ajoute et perturbe
d'ores et déjà les usagers de l'aéroport
pour le Caraïbes monsieur le ministre
notre aéroport fait face à une pénurie
de contrôleur aérien en effet faute
d'effectif suffisant l'aéroport Pôle
Caraïbes principal plateforme reliant
notre territoire avec le monde en
matière de transport de personnes
infrastructures essentielles en matière
de continuité territoriale pour notre
région sera fermée du 23 au 25 juin une
fermeture que nous avons déjà connue les
21 et 22 février dernier
l'aéroport dispose à ce jour de néfertif
de 24 agents dont 19 sont totalement
opérationnels alors que 31 postes sont
nécessaires afin d'assurer un
fonctionnement dit normal les
conséquences sont graves et importantes
avec des vols et des rotations reportées
des passagers non acheminés et parfois
des évacuations sanitaires annulées face
à l'urgence de la situation les réponses
ne sont pas au rendez-vous notre
territoire ne peut pas attendre la
formation de nouveaux contrôleur d'ici
18 mois d'autres alternatives sont
envisageables telles que la recherche
sur le plan au plan national d'autres
agents le transfert d'effectif à partir
de plateformes proches comme Fort de
France
ou la mutualisation des effectifs entre
la Guadeloupe et la Martinique aussi
monsieur le ministre dans un contexte
exceptionnel et pour prévenir d'autres
perturbations qui pourraient s'avérer
plus graves en matière de sécurité le
gouvernement pourrait-il mettre en place
des mesures d'urgence afin de renforcer
les effectifs de contrôleur aérien
Guadeloupe et puis pourriez-vous nous
les préciser
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre délégué en charge les
outre-mer Monsieur Jean-François caraco
désolé
c'est l'actrice et sénateur monsieur le
créateur Théophile vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur la pénurie d'effective
des contrôleurs aériens et notamment
aussi sur son impact sur la sécurité
civile en Guadeloupe
je connais votre mobilisation sur ce
sujet en effet vous avez raison le
service de navigation aérienne anti
Guyane se trouve actuellement dans une
situation difficile de sous-effectif
celle qui celle-ci le contrat fermé les
services de contrôle aérien toutes les
nuits et en matinée chaque fois que
l'effectif en journée n'est pas
suffisant en réaction le directeur
compétent engageait un important travail
de dialogue social notamment pour
garantir d'une part un maintien du
service et d'autre part des conditions
d'exercice satisfaisantes pour les
contrôleurs le transport d'urgence et je
veux le dire ici et notamment sanitaire
est garantie par le dragon 971 capable
d'intervenir 24 heures sur 24 pas de
danger sur la sécurité civile le Sénat
travaille d'arrache-pied pour établir un
nouveau tour de service qui prévoit qu'a
effectivement ce temps on élargit et en
sécurise l'offre de service sur la plage
6h45 23h ce qui correspond à la demande
des compagnies aériennes par ailleurs et
c'est là le principal
cette contrôleur aérien sont
actuellement en formation sur place et
si nouveau contrôleur aériens de pas
arriver d'ici la rentrée et non pas dans
18 mois je m'en suis entretenu ce matin
même avec le DGAC le ministre des
légumes transport travaille par ailleurs
des mesures de fidélisation
d'optimisation des temps de formation
locale cette situation n'affectant rien
la sécurité et je pense que d'ici
quelques semaines elle devrait
s'améliorer pour les vols civils
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
veut son épeler pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président chers collègues
j'associe Rachid themal sénateur du
Val-d'Oise à ma question madame la
Première ministre a avoué l'indiqué que
le gouvernement n'avait pas suffisamment
associé les collectivités territoriales
sur la question du point d'indice en
effet cette décision impose aux
assemblées locales dans le budget voté
depuis le 15 avril de revoir leur copie
deux mois après cette méthode est un
manque de considération notoire
vis-à-vis des élus locaux d'autant plus
irritant que le coût est loin d'être
anodin annoncé à un milliard le matin de
l'annonce ce montant à doubler
l'après-midi
depuis 2017 les décisions imposées sont
nombreuses suppression de la TH contre
la vie des associations contrat de
Cahors et loi de programmation par
lesquelles vous imposez 13 milliards
d'économies augmentation du point
d'indice dès 2022 sans plus de
consultation ni de compensation
qu'aujourd'hui plan d'eau plan vélo
annoncé unilatéralement et vous laissez
les élus locaux assumer seul la mise en
œuvre la liste pourrait s'allonger mais
le temps manque le gouvernement a
démontré son incapacité à contenir le
déficit public et en même temps vous
demandez aux collectivités de participer
à un plan d'économie de 10 milliards que
vous savez l'état incapable de réaliser
le ministre chargé des collectivités
s'inquiétait en février dernier de la
frilosité à investir devant les
conséquences de l'inflation et en même
temps contradiction le ministre de
l'Économie propose la mise en place de
l'auto-assurance qui va mettre en danger
l'investissement local nous devons
parler enfin réellement des prélèvements
obligatoires de leur niveau de leur
assiette et de leur pertinence notamment
pour recréer un lien entre les
industries et les territoires et en même
temps vous élevez un totem à la baisse
des impôts et lancer des populistes
balance ton maire ou encore en avoir
pour mes impôts qui mettent en danger le
consentement même à l'impôt que
comptez-vous mettre en place pour
répondre enfin à l'exigence de justice
pour les territoires merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes délégués en charge des
comptes publics
je suis à talnon Monsieur bichu
mais nous sommes ravis accueillir
monsieur Béchu pour pour une réponse
aussi simple voilà monsieur le Président
d'abord en vous remerciant pour la
mancheétude avec laquelle vous avez
accepté que je supplay Gabriel Attal
pour répondre à cette question et
ensuite pour saluer la haute assemblée
et le sénateur est blé la question du
rapport entre les collectivités locales
et l'État n'est pas nouvelle monsieur le
sénateur et quand vous pointez les
marges d'amélioration que nous avons en
termes de dialogue beaucoup ici se
souviennent que le totem de la baisse
des dotations qui a été porté par des
gouvernements que vous avez soutenus
entre 2012 et 2017 avec conduit dans des
conditions bien plus considérables à
moindre et le niveau des collectivités
territoriales
ensuite
ensuite ensuite ensuite
vous évoquez un certain nombre de sujets
qui de mon point de vue doivent être
distingués
d'abord sur la hausse du point chaque
année la difficulté à trouver un
dispositif dès lors que c'est l'État qui
détermine le hausse du point qui vaut
pour toutes les fonctions publiques et
que nous n'avons pas dans notre pays
jusqu'à maintenant considérer qu'il
pourrait y avoir des trajectoires
distinctes sur les fonctions publiques
en fonction des employeurs conduit à ce
qu'on est systématiquement un ce
scénario dans lequel il y a un
dispositif qui est proposé par l'État
dans la consultation en coulisses il est
rare que les collectivités s'opposent à
des revalorisations de points qui
permettent de compenser l'inflation
ayant ensuite un jeu de demande de
compensation budgétaire mais je ne pense
pas que vos propos étaient une manière
de regretter le 1,5% d'augmentation au
1er juillet du traitement des
fonctionnaires de ce pays dans le
contexte que nous connaissons
alors puisque je sais que derrière
l'artifice de la présentation que vous
avez choisi il y a une question plus
sérieuse sur le niveau de dialogue entre
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales je veux vous dire que ce
rendez-vous il approche il approche dans
le cadre précisément de la planification
écologique et de la réunion que j'ai eu
l'honneur de présider à la demande de la
première ministre avec toutes les
associations d'élus sur comment au titre
de la planification le mouvement qui va
constituer à donner aux collectivités
les moyens d'accélérer sur l'atténuation
et sur l'adaptation doit se faire quel
partage de responsabilité et de
contraintes et vous y serez évidemment
en tant que sénateur associé
[Applaudissements]
les collectivités ne veulent plus des
transferts de compétences sans
concertation et sans compensation
surtout quand il y a de l'inflation
monsieur le ministre elle demande plus
d'autonomie elles ne veulent pas de
discours condescendants de l'État elles
exigent son soutien pour affronter les
besoins et les difficultés du quotidien
pas de réponse sur ce point les
collectivités et les élus demandent plus
de respect et plus de considération
merci
mais la parole de madame la Présidente
Nathalie Delattre pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
insupportables et le premier mot qui
vient à l'esprit pour qualifier
l'ignoble attaque subie avant-hier par
une famille bordelaise mes pensées vont
vers cette petite fille sa grand-mère et
leur famille après l'agression dont
elles ont été victimes en rentrant à
leur domicile
mais remerciements vont aux forces de
l'ordre pour l'interpellation rapide
mais qualifiée de difficile de
l'agresseur
se faire agresser ça arrive à tout le
monde moi aussi ça m'est arrivé c'est la
réponse sidérante apporter lors d'une
réunion publique de celle du adjointe au
maire de Bordeaux il y a quelques jours
banalisant l'explosion de la sécurité
dans notre ville
je pourrais alors vous questionner
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur une
fois encore sur l'absolu nécessité
d'affecter une unité de CRS à demeure à
Bordeaux je pourrais monsieur le garder
ça vous réinterroger sur la suspension
récente des incarcérations des hommes au
centre pénitentiaire de Gradignan en
raison de la surpopulation carcérale
laissant ainsi des individus dangereux
sur la voie publique même si un nombre
conséquent de détenus se retrouve en
prison alors que ces derniers
nécessiterait avant tout d'être admis
dans des hôpitaux psychiatriques c'est
donc vers vous monsieur le ministre de
la Santé que je me tourne une fois de
plus j'avais initié ici une mission avec
mes collègues Philippe Bas et Jean-Sol
sur l'expertise psychiatrique en matière
pénale tant notre société son pacte
républicain police justice sont de plus
en plus menacées par la sous-estimation
des problèmes psychiatriques souvent
couplés à des addictions liées à la
drogue l'effet divers quotidien en
atteste malheureusement
il faut de nouveaux hôpitaux
psychiatriques il faut une politique sur
la psychiatrie ambitieuse et financée je
vous demandais il y a quelques semaines
ici qu'elles deviennent grandes causes
nationales combien de drames faudra-t-il
égrainer pour vous en convaincre je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est obéissent de la santé de la
prévention monsieur Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
séatrice Delattre comme vous je tiens
tout d'abord à exprimer ma solidarité
celle du gouvernement tout entier envers
les victimes de cette odieuse agression
et je sais que l'ensemble des
parlementaires partage ce sentiment
vous avez cité mes collègues messieurs
Darmanin vous avez raison parce que nous
travaillons deux concerts sur l'autorité
de la première ministre sur ce problème
qui est global global parce que nous
faisons aussi face à un problème de
société problème de société de rapport à
l'autre de civilité de rapport à la
violence face à cela nous devons
mobiliser tous les outils en les en
particulier notre capacité bien sûr à
identifier à traiter les problèmes
psychiatriques ou psychologiques le
système de santé
des difficultés oui nous le savons le
système de la psychiatrie également
suite à des décennies de gestion
comptable aveugles pour autant des 2018
nous avons agi en lançant une la feuille
de route ambitieuse sur la santé mentale
et la psychiatrie qui a été renforcée en
2021 par les premières Assises de la
santé mentale et de la psychiatrie
présidée est lancé par le Président de
la République les réponses que nous
construisons en priorité s'inscrivent
aussi il faut le savoir dans du temps
long je pense par exemple au
développement de la prévention au
développement aujourd'hui des 43000
secouristes en santé mentale le
développement des compétences
psychosociales à l'école les actions de
prévention du suicide le numéro 31 14
plus de 300 000 appels depuis sa
création le dispositif vigilance la
prise en charge également de plus de 130
000 patients grâce à mon soutien psy
300.000 consultations le développement
des centres médico-psychologiques des
maisons des adolescents désormais une
par département depuis un peu moins d'un
an et qui ont accompagné plus de 100 000
adolescents en difficulté avec leur
famille
tout cela bien sûr n'est pas suffisant
au regard des enjeux que tous les pays
développés rencontrent en matière de
santé mentale soyez en tout cas assuré
de ma détermination à agir sans faille
avec l'ensemble des professionnels et je
le sais l'ensemble des parlementaires
pour trouver des solutions assez
difficultés sur la santé mentale
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
salmon pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Le Bourget serait-il le salon
de l'illusion le salon de l'avion
magique on y voit depuis lundi
l'ensemble de la filière aéronautique et
le Président nous annonçait un avion
propre un avion vert pour demain ou
après demain bien entendu la recherche
d'alternatives au kérosène est
indispensable et l'on doit y mettre les
moyens là où le bât blesse c'est dans le
message qui est véhiculé ne changeons
pas les habitudes la technologie va tout
régler la sobriété d'usage est
complètement inexistante dans le
discours bien pire on parle de
doublement du trafic d'ici 2040
avion électrique avion à hydrogène avion
biocarburant sont présentés le problème
est que l'électrique pour les moyens est
pas pour demain que l'avion à hydrogène
est loin d'être mature et pose encore
d'énormes défis technologiques que la
biomasse nécessaire au biocarburant
n'est pas illimité car il faudra demain
choisir entre les avions les portes
containers les camions chauffer les
logements et se nourrir un bon
greenwashing qui n'a d'autre but que de
remettre à deux mains ce que nous devons
faire dès aujourd'hui c'est à dire
réguler le secteur aérien stopper sa
croissance et lui faire payer le prix de
sa pollution monsieur le ministre
accorde des solutions politiques
maintenant afin que la trajectoire du
transport aérien soit conforme à nos
engagements de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre merci
pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste la transition écologique mais
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Christophe Béchu
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur salmon
je ne peux pas croire à l'instant que
dans vos propos il y a le regret qui est
la recherche d'aller vers un avion qui
soit moins émetteur je ne peux pas
croire à l'instant qui est dans vos
propos l'arrière-pensée de vous dire que
pour rendre l'écologie populaire il
convient de la présenter sous son jour
le plus punitif et je ne peux pas croire
un instant qu'il y ait dans vos propos
le regret que nous accueillons en ce
moment dans notre pays le plus grand
salon aéronautique du monde et que ce
salon soit précisément consacré au moyen
de faire en sorte de décarboner
l'aviation
à partir de ce moment là
trois choses simples
la trajectoire de décarbonation dans
tous les domaines elle s'appuie toujours
sur un triptyque vouloir
ne retenir qu'un de ces trois piliers
c'est manquer à l'équilibre dont nous
avons besoin il faut de la sobriété il
faut de l'efficacité et il faut de
l'innovation si une partie des gens
expliquent que il faut condamner
l'innovation et qu'on y arrivera que par
la sobriété et que d'autres disent qui
ne font rien changer à nos usages et
qu'on n'y arrivera par l'innovation ces
deux chemins nous emmènent dans le mur
très concrètement la sobriété c'est
d'abord le fait que nous sommes le
premier pays à avoir interdit les vols
de moins de 2h30 quand il existe une
alternative en train
ensuite la sobriété c'est de faire en
sorte de privilégier le train de relever
la fiscalité sur le kérosène comme nous
l'avons fait l'année dernière pour
éviter d'avoir un avantage fiscal sur le
kérosène par rapport à l'essence et ce
sont les 100 milliards d'euros
d'investissement dans le ferroviaire
pour qu'il y ait des alternatives
crédible et à l'heure l'efficacité c'est
la baisse du poids c'est l'évolution des
moteurs avec un enjeu qui n'est pas
seulement national parce qu'il y a non
seulement les émissions françaises mais
dans les 3% des missions mondiales 50%
de ses émissions mondiales sont faites à
partir d'avions qui sont fabriqués en
Europe donc l'impact de l'innovation il
aura lieu partout ça n'est pas un
gouvernement qui décide du doublement du
trafic ce sont les prévisions sur la
base des décisions des individus et des
habitants de cette planète les deux axes
d'innovation annoncés par le Président
de la République ils sont simples
travailler sur les moteurs travailler
effectivement sur des alternatives en
termes de carburant et j'insiste devant
vous pour pas que ce soit caricaturé il
s'agit pas de prendre des terres
agricoles pour cultiver les
biocarburants il s'agit d'aller faire
des savent des carburants durables à
partir des résidus de bois d'algues ou
d'huile usag ées
monsieur le ministre c'est dommage vous
n'avez pas écouté mon introduction je
vous ai pourtant clairement dit que la
recherche était indispensable à vous
caricaturer c'est très facile mais par
contre ce qui est irresponsable c'est de
faire mine que la technologie va nous
sauver la sobriété dans les usages c'est
indispensable et on doit commencer par
cela le monde que vous nous préparez
c'est un monde à plus 4 degrés un monde
dont personne ne sait à quoi il va
ressembler il faut vraiment aller de
l'avant c'est ce qu'on attend de vous et
les politiques ça sert à cela ce n'est
pas de reporter à demain ce qui peut
être fait aujourd'hui
la parole est à notre collègue Emmanuel
Capu
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
Républiques et territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre lundi se tenait les assises de
Bercy
le gouvernement y a tenu un langage de
fermeté pour réduire les dépenses
publiques avec un objectif clair
10 milliards d'euros d'économies d'ici
la fin du quinquennat et je salue cette
annonce
elle a le mérite de chlore pour de bons
l'air du quoi qu'il en coûte l'inflation
et la croissance devrait être assez en
2023 la politique d'échecs ne se
justifie donc plus
notre groupe soutient cette démarche les
dépenses et la dette publique n'ont
jamais été aussi élevées il devient donc
urgent de remettre de l'ordre dans nos
comptes
mais dans cette période anxiogène la
tâche s'annonce ardu sans Prée
aujourd'hui les débats budgétaires de
l'automne je veux revenir sur une
annonce faites lundi par la première
ministre le retour en septembre de la
loi de programmation de finances
publiques
cette loi de programmation avait été
adoptée au Sénat dans un esprit de
responsabilité et par solidarité avec
nos partenaires européens ce texte devra
préciser le cadre légal de réduction des
dépenses publiques il devra aussi
indiquer la contribution des
collectivités à cet effort partagé
monsieur le ministre les collectivités
font déjà des efforts conséquents vous
le savez et pour cause la règle d'or les
contraints à équilibrer leur budget les
collectivités ne représentent que 20%
des dépenses publiques et moins de 10%
de la dette autrement dit pour remettre
de l'ordre dans les comptes il ne serait
ni juste ni efficace de demander des
efforts supplémentaires aux
collectivités territoriales
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous donc
nous garantir que la loi de
programmation ne mettra pas les
collectivités à contribution
on veut répondre la parole est
communiste déléguée chargez les comptes
publics monsieur Attal
s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Emmanuel Capu effectivement
nous avons annoncé dans le cadre du
nouveau programme de stabilité que nous
avions décidé de revoir la charge de
l'effort et on l'a fait notamment à la
suite des échanges que nous avons eu au
Sénat et vous avez été vous-même
personnellement monsieur Capu une vigie
aussi sur ce sujet de l'effort des
collectivités locales en nous invitant
en nous invitant à avoir un effort plus
important en direction de l'État que
pour les collectivités locales je
rappelle que ce qui était prévu quand on
a présenté la loi de programmation des
finances publiques c'est une baisse de
0,4% des dépenses de l'État en volume et
de 0,5% pour les collectivités locales
et que dans la nouvelle voie de
programmation que nous vous présenterons
au mois de septembre dans les évolutions
que nous y introduirons nous prévoirons
désormais un effort bien plus important
pour l'État à -08%
je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
en réponse à Madame apourceau poli on a
besoin les uns des autres on n'arrivera
pas à relever le défi de la transition
écologique si l'État et les
collectivités n'agissent pas de concert
et pour agir de concerts il nous faut
garder le contrôle sur nos finances
publiques des endettés le pays moi je ne
pose pas les 3% et les trois degrés je
considère que si on veut être capable de
relever le défi de la transition
écologique il nous faut garder le
contrôle sur les finances publiques
remettre vraiment de l'ordre dans nos
comptes de manière à disposer des marges
de manœuvre budgétaire qui nous
permettront d'investir partout où c'est
nécessaire pour relever ce défi donc on
avancera ensemble Bruno Le Maire a
effectivement fait un certain nombre de
propositions à l'occasion des Assises il
a notamment proposé ce mécanisme
d'auto-assurance des collectivités
locales lorsqu'il y a un surcroît
exceptionnel de recettes de manière à ce
que ces fonds et ses moyens puissent
venir soutenir les collectivités locales
qui en ont besoin lorsque survient une
crise c'est une proposition qui est mise
dans le débat nous allons continuer à
avancer l'année dernière on a les
dialogues de Bercy pour construire le
budget nous allons rééditer l'opération
cette année en essayant de la faire
encore mieux c'est à dire avec davantage
de réunions davantage d'échanges pour
construire à la fois le budget 2024 mais
aussi la trajectoire et les moyens dont
état collectivités locales sécurité
sociale nous serons capables de rester
ces défis pour notre pays merci vous
avez quelques secondes monsieur Capu
merci monsieur le ministre vous le savez
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous êtes
élu local vous connaissez l'exaspération
des élus locaux ils sont prêts à faire
des efforts à condition qu'on diminue
les normes qu'on diminue le nombre de
contraintes et surtout qu'on leur laisse
l'autonomie financière dans leur
collectivité
je vais te donner la parole notre
collègue Gérard longuqué mais avant
qu'il la prenne
mais avant qu'il la prenne
je voudrais saluer Gérard Longuet qui a
pris la décision à la fin de nos
sessions de de pas renouveler son mandat
il a été 22 ans dans cette émission il a
été président du groupe UMP et il a été
à la commission des finances j'allais
dire un orateur et quelqu'un qui a donné
toujours beaucoup d'élévation et je
voudrais saluer le travail qu'il a fait
comme président de l'Office
Parlementaire l'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques
bon ça c'était pas prévu
non non
oui merci monsieur le Président ce
n'était pas prévu
je souhaite simplement rester d'une
sérénité à toute épreuve car en effet
après 45 ans de mandat parlementaire le
jeune Gabriel Attal n'était pas né alors
que j'étais déjà député
c'est pour ça que je remercie de
répondre à cet instant avant-hier Bruno
Le Maire a inauguré installé les
premières Assises des finances publiques
comme écrivain je l'accepte mais très
honnêtement comme metteur en scène il
est nul pourquoi il s'est trompé de lieu
il y a un lieu pour les finances
publiques ça s'appelle le Parlement
c'est l'Assemblée nationale et c'est le
Sénat
il s'est trompé ensuite il s'est trompé
ensuite parce qu'il y a pas une première
assise et on verra plus tard il y a une
urgence absolue pour redresser les
finances de notre pays et ma question
est d'une grande simplicité même si mon
excellent collègue a pu semble la voir
ouverte et bien je vais enfoncer ma le
sujet est posé la question suivante
pourquoi diable n'avez-vous pas
répondu à la commande de madame la
Première ministre Elisabeth borne de
présenter en s'était en avril de
présenter en juillet la loi de
programmation des finances publiques 23
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
ministre Gérard Longuet moi je réponds
toujours aux commandes de la première
ministre et j'ai entendu lundi une
commande de la première ministre a
présenté la loi de programmation des
finances publiques au mois de septembre
prochain et donc évidemment nous nous
mettons en ordre de marche avec Bruno Le
Maire pour la présenter en septembre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on la présente en
septembre je pense que c'était ça
derrière votre question parce que ça
davantage de sens de la présenter avec
le projet de loi de finances étant donné
des choix budgétaires majeurs que nous
allons devoir faire dans le cadre du PLF
pour qu'il soit intégré dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
plutôt que de représenter une loi de
programmation des finances publiques en
juillet et de devoir revenir ensuite en
septembre après la présentation du PLF
pour adapter le texte raison pour
laquelle nous reviendrons avec cette
programmation dont je rappelle qu'elle
avait été adoptée au Sénat avec un
quantum d'économie très important
supplémentaire qui avait été décidé par
votre assemblée je pense que ça sera
intéressant qu'on puisse avoir le débat
désormais sur où est-ce que vous situez
ces économies supplémentaires et on
partagera chacun nos propositions et on
pourra échanger sur ce sujet là puisque
une fois avoir arbitré un quantum je
pense que c'est important d'être capable
de dire où est-ce que on identifie les
économies dans chaque périmètre
ministériel voilà évidemment monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le ministre je veux au
nom du gouvernement et à l'occasion de
cette dernière question au gouvernement
que vous prononcez ici vous rendre
hommage rendre hommage à votre parcours
c'est vrai que j'avais 12 ans je crois
quand vous êtes rentrés ici au Sénat
vous avez eu l'occasion de le souligner
mais du coup je dois dire je me suis
intéressé très jeune à la vie politique
et donc j'ai l'impression de vous avoir
connu très jeune et d'avoir suivi votre
voix singulière dans le débat politique
en tant que ministre en tant que
parlementaire en tant président de
conseils régional aussi vous avez porté
une voie je crois importante dans le
débat politique et je suis absolument
convaincu que vous continuerez à porter
cette voie dans notre débat d'idées y
compris en dehors de cette assemblée je
vous remercie monsieur longuet
oui merci monsieur le Président je crois
avoir regardé un petit peu de temps pour
vous répondre et vous dire très
simplement que votre problème est un
problème de majorité politique soyez
très soyez rassuré vous n'êtes aucun
président de la République française
depuis l'élection au suffrage
universelle n'a été élu à la majorité
absolue au premier tour tous ont eu à
gérer des majorités compliquées seul
sur les 14 élections législatives depuis
à cette occasion 7 3 et 4 ont le
président obtenu une majorité à travers
son parti cela veut dire quoi cela veut
dire madame la Première ministre qu'au
cœur des institutions de la Cinquième
République il y a une réalité
parlementaire qui oblige le président de
la République a considéré que ceux qui
ont l'ont rallié au deuxième tour
méritent d'exister et d'être prise en
considération effective
c'est exactement ce qui manque
aujourd'hui je ne parle pas
je conclus très simplement vous avez
trois choix vous avez en effet
la coalition gouvernementale
c'est pas prévu et c'est pas dans le
caractère du Président vous avez la
cohabitation dans votre propre camp en
choisissant un premier ministre dont
vous pensez qu'il sera plus fédérateur
et vous avez enfin la dissolution je
regrette de ne pas être parlementaire
pour ces trois événements
la parole est à d'autres collègues
Pierre Frogier pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et dans l'attente
toujours dans la tente mais désormais sa
longue histoire se poursuivra dans la
France
lors de son dernier voyage à Nouméa le
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer a
engagé des échanges avec les différentes
forces politiques qui devraient aboutir
nous l'espérons à la co-construction du
solution d'avenir je tiens à lui donner
acte de sa détermination et alors
remercié pour ma part j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de vous le dire je me tiens
vos dispositions enfin de vous
accompagner sur ce chemin
madame la Première ministre pour
parvenir à cette solution d'avenir nous
devons franchir un premier obstacle le
renouvellement des assemblées de
province l'année prochaine et seul une
réforme du corps électoral pour ces
élections les rendra possible il vous
appartient donc au plus vite nous
proposer les voix et les moyens pour y
parvenir je veux rappeler encore et
encore qu'à la signature de l'Accord de
Nouméa le droit de vote était acquis au
terme du dorée d'une durée de résidence
de 10 ans en Nouvelle-Calédonie la
réforme constitutionnelle de 2007 qui
nous a été imposé y a mis un terme en
fermant à compter de 1998 l'accès au
corps électoral
mais surtout dans la première ministre
ces référendums successifs ont laissé
derrière eux une population profondément
divisée
pour tenter d'y remédier il nous faudra
porter une vision politique
susceptible de fédérer et de nourrir
cette communauté de destin à laquelle
nous aspirons
une vision de façon à permettre aux
calédoniens de se projeter sur le long
terme d'avoir l'ambition d'un navire
partagé et de ne pas se laisser enfermer
dans le sol des bas institutionnels le
contenu de cette communauté de destin ce
que l'on dénomme la citoyenneté faites
de droits et de devoirs qui situera la
place de la Nouvelle-Calédonie dans la
France son identité particulière dans la
solidarité nationale madame la Première
ministre ma question est double
pouvez-vous vous engager sur un agenda
permettant la tenue des élections
provinciales avec un corps électoral
ouvert dès l'année prochaine
etes-vous prête nous accompagner pour
donner à la Nouvelle-Calédonie un
ensemble de règles qui définiront les
exigences de notre savoir-vivre ensemble
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est à madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Pierre Frogier
le processus politique défini dans
l'Accord de Nouméa est arrivé à son
terme en décembre 2021 après trois
consultations référendaires successives
organisée sous l'autorité du Président
de la République
il appartient désormais aux partenaire
politique
d'examiner la situation ainsi créée
selon les termes même de l'accord
vous le savez mon gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour accompagner les
discussions sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie en moins d'un an le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outre-mer
et le ministre chargé des Outre-mer ce
sont rendus sur place à 4 reprises pour
échanger avec l'ensemble des acteurs
calédoniens j'ai également réuni une
convention des partenaires à Paris en
octobre 2022 et rencontrer la délégation
du FLNKS et les représentants non
indépendantistes le 11 avril dernier
comme vous le savez les discussions
portent actuellement pour l'essentiel
sur les compétences sur l'exercice du
droit à l'autodétermination et sur
l'évolution du corps électoral
provincial
je l'affirme devant vous comme je l'ai
dit à la délégation du FLNKS je crois
qu'un gel indéfini du corps électoral
provincial questionnerait nos principes
démocratiques comme nos engagements
internationaux aujourd'hui les
discussions avancent et je mesure la
sensibilité de cette question le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
a fait des propositions sur une durée de
résidence minimale des échanges
techniques sont actuellement organisés
par le haut-commissaire à Nouméa et je
suis persuadé qu'une solution
consensuelle peut être trouvée sur ce
point comme sur les autres je suis prête
à inviter l'ensemble des partenaires à
partir de la fin du mois d'août pour
conclure l'accord que les Calédoniens
attendent quant aux élections
provinciales elles auront lieu en toute
état de cause en 2024 c'est un enjeu
démocratique
monsieur le sénateur l'esprit de
l'Accord de Nouméa qui doit nous
inspirer et que vous incarnez en tant
que signataire en 1998 n'est pas
seulement un mécanisme institutionnel et
juridique c'est avant tout l'ambition
profondément humaine du destin commun je
crois que cette ambition répond à
l'attente de nombreux jeunes calédoniens
alors soyons collectivement à la hauteur
des signatures des signataires des
accords de 1988 et 1998
et peut-être si vous le permettez
monsieur le Président je voudrais
terminer cette réponse en rendant
hommage à mon tour à monsieur le
président Gérard Longuet ancien ministre
et président de groupe mais aussi au
président Jean-Pierre Sueur ancien
ministre ancien président de la
commission des lois et questeur de votre
assemblée et à la sénatrice Michel
meunier qui siège dans ses travées qui
siège dans ses travées depuis 12 ans
vous êtes ici des voies qui portent
respectées pour votre connaissance fine
des dossiers et votre volonté devrait
pour les Français nous avons pu nous
opposer mais nous avons toujours su
travailler ensemble au service de la
République et de l'intérêt général je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais donner immédiatement la
parole jean-Pierre Sueur qui lui aussi
22 années au Sénat et je dois dire
sans doute un chiffre record de nombre
d'heures passées dans les fauteuils de
l'émission nous allons publier ces
œuvres complètes très bientôt et comme
président de la commission des lois
merci comme question du Sénat
merci
merci monsieur le Président c'est trop
je voulais juste vous interroger madame
la Première ministre sur ce qui s'est
passé dans la nuit du 13 mai au large de
la Grèce et qui est une honte pour notre
civilisation
750 hommes femmes enfants
entassés comme des bêtes
dans un bateau qui a péri au naufragés
et nous savons aujourd'hui que Frontex
qu'un certain nombre d'États que des
garde-côtes savaient
que c'était un péril imminent
les images de la BBC ont montré que
pendant 7 heures ce bateau était là
entre la vie et la mort est plus près de
la mort alors nous ne pouvons pas nous
résigner
à ce qu'il y ait
50600 700 morts qui viennent s'ajouter
aux dix mille des quatre ou cinq
dernières années au 20 000 ou 30 000
nous ne savons pas à ceux de la Manche
et je demande simplement madame la
Première ministre que la France pèse de
tout son poids
pour qu'il y ait vraiment une politique
pour mettre fin au naufrage de ces êtres
humains
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État
chargé des partenariats internationaux
madame crise oula sakaro polo vous avez
la parole
mais si elle est Président Mesdames
effectivement
c'est une phrase
souvenir les 14 juin au large de la
Grèce et avant tout comme vous avez dit
un drame Ouma un des plus souvenir
Méditerranée et vous avez totalement
raison oui nous ne pouvons pas se
résigner
cette tragédie nous bouleverse tous et
je voulais renouveler nos condoléances
aux familles des victimes
et bien sûr elle nous oblige car nous
devons tout mettre en oeuvre pour éviter
de nouveau drame de ce type et notamment
au niveau européen
l'accord trouvé le 8 juin par les
ministres européen de l'Intérieur
permettra d'y apporter une réponse et
européenne sur ces sujets à la question
du traitement de demande d'asile une
réponse qui doit lier responsabilité
efficacité et solidarité la France et
l'Italie sont pleinement mobilisés à ses
sens comme le soulignait hier le
président de la République et la
première ministre Georgia Meloni
mais ces drames rappelle aussi
l'importance de la coopération avec les
pays tiers en matière de sauvetage en
mer et des luttes contre les réseaux de
passeurs là encore les travaux sont en
cours au niveau européen en particulier
avec la Tunisie notre objectif est de
renforcer les capacités des
États-Unis pour mieux lutter contre ceux
qui exploitent la détresse des migrants
contre les causes profondes de l'air
exil enfin Monsieur le Kester comme
aujourd'hui c'est votre dernier question
le gouvernement et ce soit je souhaite
aussi profiter pour vous saluer attendez
ministre sénateur président de la
commission des lois mère de Orléans vous
nous avez marqué pendant 40 ans par vos
convictions
et votre engagement permanent la
République les Sénats et votre cerf
Loiret vous ne sont reconnaissants
monsieur le
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
Président puisqu'il me reste quelques
secondes je voulais dire simplement que
par rapport aux étrangers mes chers
collègues par rapport aux immigrés
il est facile
d'exploiter constamment ce sujet alors
que nous ne devons pas l'exploiter faire
de la politique politicienne facile avec
les étrangers en disant que les
étrangers sont un danger pour notre pays
mes chers collègues il y a des problèmes
qu'il faut traiter et qu'il ne faut pas
exploiter surtout lorsqu'il y a des
centaines et des milliers de personnes
qui dans la mer Méditerranée sont en
danger merci pour ce que vous ferez tous
pour bien prendre conscience qu'il nous
faut une politique énergie
impulsée par la France au niveau de
l'Europe pour sauver ses êtres humains
la parole
au président Jean-François Raffin pour
le groupe les républicains
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je partage ce propos avec ma collègue la
présidente Sophie prima en octobre 2019
la première ministre déclarait qu'on ne
peut pas signer un accord commercial
avec un pays qui ne respecte pas la
forêt amazonienne qui ne respecte pas le
traité de Paris la France ne signera pas
l'accord avec le Mercosur dans ses
conditions plus récemment lors de sa
visite au salon de l'agriculture le 25
février dernier le président Emmanuel
Macron expliqué qu'un accord avec les
pays du continent latino-américain n'est
pas possible s'il ne respecte pas comme
nous les accords de Paris ni les mêmes
contraintes environnementales et
sanitaires qu'on impose à nos
producteurs mais il y a 15 jours Olivier
bèche avait déclaré qu'il fallait
conclure cet accord avec le Mercosur qui
est en négociation depuis 23 ans la
semaine dernière la présidente de la
Commission européenne
Ursula vanderleyen à elle aussi espérer
publiquement lors de sa tournée en
Amérique latine que l'Union européenne
conclut d'ici la fin de l'année cet
accord
qui prend dans 10 jours la présidence du
Conseil de l'Union européenne sera aussi
très allante bref la barque prend l'eau
de toutes parts et nous sommes très
inquiets d'autant plus que la Commission
européenne est en mesure de tenir à
l'écart les Parlement nationaux de la
ratification de l'accord en décembre
dernier notre collègue Alain cadet bien
au fait de ce danger vous avez déjà
interrogé la question se fait plus
pressante encore aujourd'hui madame la
ministre le président Macron risque-t-il
de trahir vendredi sa parole envers le
monde agricole lorsqu'il recevra à Paris
monsieur Lula redevenu président du
Brésil
pour vous répondre
la parole est à la secrétaire d'État
chargé des partenariats internationaux
vous avez la parole
mais si elle est président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
Jean-François rapan
je vous prie tout d'abord d'excuser la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères actuellement déplacement la
France comme nombre de pays européens
exprimer ses préoccupations sur l'accord
Union européenne mercure dès 2019
notamment pour des raisons
environnementales la Commission
européenne a fait des efforts notamment
sur la question de la déforestation mais
cela reste insuffisant
des négociations sont en cours pour
apporter des réponses supplémentaires la
France a refermé trois conditions et
dispensables pour nous engager sur cet
accord les premiers comme vous avez
souligné l'accord de Paris comme élément
essentiels
développement durable de l'accord avec
la nouvelle approche de la commission
c'est à dire avec nos meilleurs
standards en matière environnementale et
sociale et en parallèle de l'accord un
programme ambitieux sous les mesures
miroirs vu les enjeux de cet accord nous
nous opposons à sa scission nous
souhaitons qu'il soit présenté au
Parlement nationaux les présidents de la
République et le président brésilienne
auront l'occasion comme vous avez dit
d'échanger sur ces sujets comme sur la
somme des enjeux bilatéraux et globaux
en mars du sommet pour un nouveau pacte
financier organisé ces deux prochaines
jours je vous remercie
monsieur le président
madame la ministre nous prenons acte
aujourd'hui de vos paroles en disant que
vous n'excluez pas le Parlement
nationaux de cette discussion et c'est
essentiel rappelez les trois clauses que
la France exige et c'est à VOUS
gouvernement au conseil de défendre les
agriculteurs français et la France en
tout cas la commission des affaires
européennes que je peux que je préside
merci
la parole est à notre collègue je suis
une guidez pour le groupe du l'Union
centriste
la question s'adresse au ministre de la
Santé de la prévention et porte sur l'un
des indicateurs clés pour évaluer la
santé d'une population cela fait 7 ans
que la mortalité infantile en France est
supérieure à la moyenne européenne alors
qu'elle était l'une des plus basses
d'Europe à la fin du 20e siècle alors
que la France figurait parmi les
meilleurs élèves en troisième position
le pays a chuté en 20e place sur 27 en
2021 2700 nourrissons de moins d'un an
ont perdu la vie en France soit 3,7
décès pour 1000 naissances vivantes
j'appelle tout particulièrement votre
attention sur l'évolution préoccupante
de certains indicateurs de santé
périnatale dans trois régions
métropolitaines l'Île-de-France le
centre Val de Loire et le Grand Est mais
aussi dans les départements ultramarins
le taux de mortalité infantile et de
8,9% à Mayotte 8,2% en Guyane et 8,1% en
Guadeloupe alors qu'il s'établit à 3,5
en France hexagonale
la Cour des comptes dans son rapport
pour sur la santé dans les outre-mer en
2012 mettez déjà en lumière le manque de
pédiatre et de gynécologue monsieur le
ministre quelles sont les explications
possibles à cette tendance
spécifiquement française quels sont les
mesures de prévention prise ou
envisagées par le gouvernement pour
endiguer cette surmortalité infantile en
outre-mer ainsi dans les quatre
départements de la France métropolitaine
à savoir la Seine-Saint-Denis le Jura
l'Indre-et-Loire et le lot je vous
remercie
merci pour vos réponses la parole et
communistes de la santé de la prévention
Monsieur François boron
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice guidez la lutte contre la
mortalité infantile est effectivement un
enjeu majeur c'est l'un des marqueurs de
l'état de notre système de santé grâce
au projet de la médecine ou politique de
santé ciblée le taux de mortalité
infantile est aujourd'hui historiquement
bas il faut s'en souvenir l'Insee le dit
d'ailleurs il est particulièrement bas
dans notre histoire néanmoins ce n'est
pas un acquis il faut continuer à
progresser il faut continuer à rester
mobilisé en effet cette étude montre
aussi et vous l'avez dit que ce taux ne
baisse plus à même légèrement augmenté
ces dernières années notamment dans la
première existence première semaine
d'existence de l'enfant
la santé des enfants ça commence dès les
premiers jours dès les premières heures
c'est pour cela que nous avons rendu la
vaccination du nourrisson obligatoire à
ce titre je m'assure contre les discours
qui continuent à relativiser voire
dénigrer l'importance de la vaccination
nous avons élargi le test systématique
de dépistage néonatal qui permet
désormais de détecter et de prendre en
charge 13 maladies graves de l'enfant
nous avons aussi déployé une stratégie
sur les 1000 premiers jours de l'enfant
pour associer parents professionnels de
santé autour de la santé physique de la
santé mentale de l'enfant bien entendu
le travail ne s'arrête pas là travailler
tous les aspects de la santé de
l'enfance c'est l'état d'esprit dans
lequel j'ai installé des Assises de la
santé de l'enfant et de la pédiatrie les
différents groupes de travail sont à
l'oeuvre depuis plusieurs mois leur
conclusion est proposition nous serons
rendus très prochainement avec un
ciblage très particulier sur la
situation de nos outre-mer par exemple
nous avons déjà pu avancer dans le cadre
de leurs travaux sur la profession et la
rénovation du métier d'infirmières
puéricultrice pour adapter la formation
et leur exercice aux nouveaux enjeux de
la prise en charge de l'enfant
sur les maternités puisque le sujet est
souvent mis en parallèle loin de toute
gestion purement comptable d'un autre
temps je veux créer un nouveau modèle
qui allie non seulement le suivi
périnatal avant et après la naissance en
proximité le plus possible mais qui
sécurise surtout l'acte d'accouchement
sur des plateaux techniques ou toutes
les compétences sont rassemblées tu vois
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez raison faut sortir
certainement pas dénigrer les
vaccinations
le taux de mentalité infantile ne baisse
plus depuis 20 ans 20 années et on est
en 20e place sur 27 en Europe mais c'est
catastrophique je suis très donc cette
phrase de macbloc dans l'étrange des
fêtes français je vais être contraint
parlant de mon pays de ne pas en parler
quand bien il est dur de devoir
découvrir les faiblesses d'une mère
douloureuse voilà j'espère que vous
allez pouvoir en tous les cas avancer
sur ce sujet parce que moi je ne reviens
pas de la place que nous avons alors
nous sommes en France merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]
donner la parole à notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues cette question s'est adressée
au ministre de l'économie et des
finances j'ai associé mes collègues
loisiers Martin et Reitman un hectare de
forêt qui brûle c'est un moyen de 46
tonnes de CO2 qui sont libérés en 2022
72000 hectares ont libéré 3 milliards et
demi de tonnes de carbone la proposition
de loi d'initiative sénatoriale visant à
renforcer la prévention et la lutte
contre l'intensification et l'extension
du risque incendie a fait l'objet d'un
accord en commission mixte paritaire
cependant les députés sous la pression
comptable de Bercy ont refusé d'accorder
aux collectivités territoriales le
bénéfice de la réduction de cotisations
patronales en contrepartie de la mise à
disposition d'employés sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires pour les services d'incendie
et de secours outre qu'une telle mesure
aurait pu alléger une longue recharge
financière les collectivités et plus
particulièrement les plus petites la
sécurité civile se trouvera en pratique
privée d'un vivier de recrutement
important de sapeur-pompiers volontaire
dans un contexte pourtant marquer par
une crise aiguë d'évocation autre regret
le renoncement des députés à une mesure
forte en faveur de la protection massive
de la forêt par le débroussaillement
reconnu par les 10 comme moyen de
limiter la propagation du feu où tout au
moins afin que la forêt soit plus
aisément défendable l'étude sur la
valeur du Sauvet parle d'elle-même un
euro investi dans la prévention contre
les feux de forêt permet d'éviter 20 à
25 euros de dépenses quand elle est en
feu lorsqu'on envisage de dépenser des
milliards pour décarboner notre économie
vous refusez de dépenser 4 millions pour
aider les collectivités à mieux défendre
la forêt et d'accompagner les
particuliers à engager leur première
opérations de débroussaillement quel
paradoxe le texte issu de la CMP manque
d'ambition sur son volet financier au
nom des considérations budgétaires de
court terme et je le regrette
monsieur le ministre il ne faut pas
penser à la forêt que lorsqu'elle brûle
quand l'État va-t-il prendre ses
responsabilités pour qu'en dépit du
changement climatique la forêt continue
à jouer son rôle de plus de carbone
pour vous répondre la parole est la
madame sollia Bacquet secrétaire d'État
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Baki je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier pour la proposition de loi que
vous portez avec Anne-Catherine Loisier
Pascal Martin et Olivier Reitman qui
viennent faire l'objet d'une CMP
conclusive à l'issue de la procédure
accélérée votre produit de proposition
apporte de nombreuses avancées dans
l'appréhension de la protection de nos
forêts avec les laboration d'une
stratégie nationale et
interministérielle de défense vous créez
un continuum de prise en compte de ce
risque depuis la prévention jusqu'aux
actions de reboisement et de
reconstitution de forêt plus résiliente
le travail que vous avez mené a fait
l'objet d'un large consensus les
échanges avec l'ensemble des partenaires
et acteurs ont été très nombreux et je
m'en félicite tous reconnaissent la
qualité des travaux comme les très
grandes avancées que vous avez proposées
concernant la mesure relative à
l'exonération de charges sociales pour
les employeurs vous avez fait le choix
d'une expérimentation pendant trois ans
ce dispositif est inédit il va permettre
à nos concitoyens qui s'investissent
pour le bien public d'être encore plus
disponible pour mener des actions de
secours
le choix a été fait dès le début de ne
pas intégrer les collectivités
territoriales en tant que bénéficiaire
il existe vous le savez d'autres
mécanismes qui les concernent
directement comme la possibilité de
diminuer leur contribution obligatoire
au service d'incendie et de secours si
elles mettent à disposition leurs
agences nous n'avons pas retenu non plus
la mise en place du crédit d'impôt sur
les obligations légales de
débroussaillement parce qu'il s'agit ici
il s'agissait ici pardon de mettre les
bonnes dépenses au bon endroit et cette
loi n'était pas le vecteur le plus
opportun cela n'enlève en rien la
qualité de cette loi une loi
consensuelle qui va mieux nous armer
pour faire face à ce défi du changement
climatique le gouvernement adresse un
message de soutien à l'ensemble des
acteurs au premier rang desquels les
sapeurs-pompiers qui vont dans les jours
à venir de voir lutter activement contre
les feux vous pourrez toujours compter
sur notre soutien je vous remercie
merci je vais céder la parole de notre
collègue
Michel meunier
elle aussi c'est une de ces dernières
interventions
dans notre hémicycle je voudrais moi
aussi saluer son travail bien sûr à la
commission des affaires sociales nous
avons toutes en tête le rapport qu'elle
a fait sur bien vieillir avec Bernard
bonne il y a peu de temps j'aurais salué
devant les collègues la vice-présidente
du comité de déontologie parlementaire
remarquable qu'elle a été avec Arnaud
Bazin
bon il est parti merci
merci beaucoup
c'est avec gravité que je pose ma
question au ministre de la Santé de la
prévention monsieur le ministre
l'insistance de votre gouvernement a
ignorer les alertes des professionnels
du soin à des tricoter notre modèle
social à opposer les Français précaires
aux Français méritants plonge un bon
nombre d'entre eux dans une détresse
physique et mentale insupportable l'état
de santé de notre pays se dégrade les
dépenses de santé augmentent c'est
normal les dépenses de santé augmentent
et vous faites la chasse aux arrêts
maladie et diminuer le remboursement des
soins dentaires c'est normal non ça
c'est grave grave car les dépenses
dentaires réglées par les
complémentaires seront
répercutés sur les cotisations des
mutuelles elle diminueront ainsi le
pouvoir d'achat des assurés
pas grave car les accidents du travail
touchent plus fortement le secteur du
soin ou de l'aide à domicile en raison
précisément de leur tension de
recrutement voilà le système de soins de
demain si vous ne réagissez pas monsieur
le ministre une santé à deux vitesses
des soins pour les plus aisés et leur
complémentaires Premium et des
renoncements aux soins pour les plus
précaires coincés dans la file des
urgences attendant d'être soigné par
d'autres précaires ma question est
simple allez vous changer de logique et
enfin investir dans le système de soins
et le recrutement des soignantes et des
soignants plutôt de que de conforter ce
cercle vicieux d'austérité sanitaire
[Applaudissements]
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
monsieur Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Michel meunier merci de me
réserver votre dernière question dans
cette dans cette hémicycle cela me
permet de saluer votre carrière au
service de nos concitoyens et également
votre question va me permettre de
rétablir quelques vérités
nous sommes le gouvernement la majorité
qui avons fait le 100% santé sur
l'optique les prothèses auditives le
dentaire c'est un progrès majeur en
matière d'accès à la santé pour nos
concitoyens ceci n'est bien sûr par
remis en cause ceci dément le principe
la volonté que nous pourriez avoir de
faire une médecine à deux vitesses loin
de là ce progrès nous l'avons construit
avec les complémentaires santé
absolument pas en opposition avec elle
bien au contraire et depuis que je suis
arrivé au ministère je les rencontre
très régulièrement depuis 2011 en raison
de la progression des affections de
longue durée dans notre pays mais aussi
des nombreuses dépenses prises en compte
par 100% par l'Assurance Maladie la
sécurité sociale assume une part de plus
en plus importante des dépenses par
rapport aux complémentaires
son intervention de la sécurité sociale
lors des prises en charge a augmenté de
3 points pendant que celles des
complémentaires diminués de 1 point est
celle des ménages de deux points
aujourd'hui nous devons garantir
l'avenir de notre système de santé
l'accès à tous aux innovations pour
faire face aux nouveaux enjeux comme par
exemple le virage préventif dans ce
cadre tous les acteurs doivent faire des
efforts y compris les complémentaires
c'est le sens de la mesure à laquelle
vous faites référence qui prévoit un
plus grand engagement financier des
complémentaires dans les soins dentaires
afin de mettre en place aux côtés de
l'Assurance Maladie un 100% prévention
réussir l'objectif d'une génération sans
Carrie
s'agissant des arrêts maladie oui nous
examinons soigneusement la situation
bien sûr afin d'en limiter les abus ou
qu'ils soient je serai bien sûr très
vigilant au sein de ce gouvernement à ce
que les Français se voient indemniser à
juste proportion lorsqu'ils sont malades
vous le voyez madame la sénatrice ce
gouvernement a une ligne claire oui il
est légitime d'identifier des marges
d'économie là où cela est possible et
supportable pour garantir la pérennité
de nos systèmes de protection mais cela
ne se fera jamais au détriment de
l'accès aux soins pour tous les Français
je vous remercie madame meunier
monsieur le ministre nous ne serons pas
d'accord vous sapez l'hôpital public
vous
ne répondez pas à nos propositions par
exemple de mettre un ratio de soignants
par patient et vous ne répondez pas non
plus à la colère de celles et ceux qui
cotisent et qui voit le nombre de
soignants diminués et qui surtout ne
voient pas le fruit de leur effort
la parole est à notre collègue elles
achètent pour le groupe les républicains
merci merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse
malheureusement que constater
l'affaiblissement de l'autorité de
l'État pour eux c'est la double peine
celle de payer et de continuer à subir
un exemple en Alsace ou une collectivité
est confrontée à l'arrivée de 44
caravanes elle a investi 700000 € pour
créer une aire de passage à l'heure
actuelle l'air est totalement déserte
les gens du voyage refusant de s'y
installer lui préférant un terrain de
football à cela il faut ajouter des
incivilités des dégradations commis sur
les branchements et les compteurs d'eau
monsieur le ministre cette situation
n'est tout simplement plus tenable il
est temps que ces agissements illégaux
s'arrêtent et que le non-respect de la
loi soit sanctionné il est urgent
d'adapter les lois Besson mais également
de renforcer le travail de coordination
en amont monsieur le ministre les élus
locaux ont pris leur responsabilité en
créant des airs le Sénat a pris les
siennes en votant notamment le texte de
notre collègue Patrick chaise pour
faciliter la procédure d'évacuation et
durcir les sanctions quand allez-vous
enfin prendre les vôtres
pour vos réponses
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président madame la sénatrice
Schalke le sujet des installations
illicite est en effet un sujet fort et
mis de l'Intérieur d'outre-mer que je
représente aujourd'hui est pleinement
mobilisée d'abord il nous fallait mieux
réprimer c'est le sens de la voile de
2018 qui assoupli les conditions
permettant de saisir le préfet pour
mettre en demeure les gens du voyage de
quitter les terrains occupés les
sititement avec emploi de la force si
nécessaire elle a également renforcé les
sections les sanctions pénales pour ce
délit de six mois d'emprisonnement et
3750 euros d'amende à un an
d'emprisonnement et 7500 euros d'angle
ça a été durci fortement mais le sujet
des installations illicites est aussi
lié aux conditions d'accueil sur
lesquelles nous devons collectivement
travailler ainsi l'ensemble des préfets
a été mobilisé en janvier 2022 afin de
relancer les schémas départementaux
d'accueil et d'habitat des gens du
voyage le bilan réalisé montre et je ne
suis pas d'accord avec vous montre en
effet que des efforts demeurent à
fournir en la matière
par ailleurs je rappelle pour la
coordination qu'un référent ministériel
Jean du voyage a été nommé celui-ci
chargé d'entretenir les relations avec
les élus et les organisations
représentatives et d'intervenir chez les
difficultés signées enfin une circulaire
a été prise de 24 avril 2023 c'est assez
récent adressé au préfet sur la gestion
des grands passages estivaux un courrier
est un voyage l'ensemble des
responsables d'associations des gens du
voyage afin de le rappeler les grands
principes informations préalable
répartition des demandes d'antan et dans
l'espace
vigilance qu'un vigilance quant à
l'intégrité
des équipements
l'intention du gouvernement est bien
d'avancée sur les deux aspects offrir
les conditions d'un meilleur accueil et
réprimer plus efficacement les
installations illicites la vie est ainsi
faite que c'est jamais simple
la parole est à notre collègue Sabine
rexeler pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
trop souvent perçu comme une charge le
patrimoine marque une culture une
identité il permet également de créer de
l'activité et de l'emploi le petit
patrimoine ne fait l'objet d'aucune
protection à moins que celle-ci ne soit
spécifiée dans les documents d'urbanisme
ce patrimoine ce sont des lavoirs des
fours à pains des calvaires mais aussi
des maisons à colombages en Alsace ou
des malumières en Bretagne ce sont les
maisons vigneronnes d'Occitanie et les
bureaux du Cantal les échoppes
bordelaises et les longères devant des
ou encore Les Chalets du Briançonnais
les meulière d'Île-de-France toutes
comme encore les chaumières normandes
les maisons basses ou les mas de
Provence
caractérisent nos régions et font
l'attractivité de notre pays
par définition se bâtit vers maculaire
et durable d'abord par sa longévité mais
aussi par sa soutenabilité car il a été
construit en fonction du climat et des
ressources locales et grâce aux qualités
que celle-ci lui confère il contribue
naturellement à une réduction
conséquente de l'utilisation du
chauffage et de la climatisation
aujourd'hui le DPE devenu opposable et
l'urgence de la décarbonation amène de
nombreux propriétaires de ce type de
bien à réaliser des travaux d'isolation
inadaptés mais subventionné et sans le
savoir il porte des atteintes parfois
fatales d'autres délaissent leur bien
qui finira dégrader puis vendus pour
s'enfoncier les ABS nous disent qu'ils
ne parviennent plus aujourd'hui à
endiguer la vague d'isolation par
l'extérieur y compris dans les secteurs
protégés
monsieur le ministre que comptez-vous
mettre en oeuvre pour empêcher que des
gestes ou des matériaux inappropriés ne
viennent porter des atteints définitives
au bâti patrimonial de notre pays
monsieur Béchu ministre de la cohésion
des territoires vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
vous êtes venus me voir tous les deux
pour insister sur le risque qu'il y
aurait avoir une vision aveugle et
uniforme des règles du DPE au mépris de
la résistance je vais utiliser un mot
qu'on utilisait pas à l'époque mais de
la résilience d'une partie de ces
maisons de pleine pierre et des types
d'habitats qui sont construits il y a
quelques jours au début du mois de juin
la ministre de la Culture est moi-même
compte tenu du lien hiérarchique que
nous avons avec les ABS avons reçu le
cri d'alarme d'une dizaine
d'associations patrimoniales qui a
relayé une partie des propositions qui
avait été faites par votre commission je
veux aussi dire à quel point ce sujet
nous le prenons au sérieux ce que nous
avons demandé aux ABS c'est de nous
aider à montrer ce qui était possible
c'est le cas quand à l'hôtel de rocklore
que j'occupe de manière temporaire
nous sommes en train d'explorer la
géothermie pour éviter pour trouver un
moyen de décarbonation qui ne touche ni
au façade ni à l'apparence du bâtiment
c'est le cas quand partout on se demande
ce qui est possible et non pas comment
on cherche l'excuse pour ne pas faire je
le dis d'autant plus volontiers que
c'est une part de notre identité de
notre âme vous avez cité les longeurs de
Vendée il m'aurait évidemment plus que
vous puissiez jusqu'au troglodyte du
saumuroir ou jusqu'à une partie des
clochettes hors du Haut-Anjou mais c'est
l'occasion pour moi de dire qu'il y a
sur nos territoires ce sera pour moi
l'occasion de saluer le président
Retailleau des collectivités je le dis
très sérieusement qui ont pris à bras le
corps la question du petit patrimoine en
mesurant que c'était à la fois un moyen
d'aller soutenir nos ruralité et c'est
ce que la première ministre a mis à
l'honneur il y a quelques jours au
travers du plan France ruralité qui va
nous permettre de mieux accompagner
l'ensemble des territoires de préserver
une partie de nos cultures et de se
préoccuper de ce qui nous permet de
préparer l'avenir en nous appuyant sur
le passé il faut une forme de transition
mais en l'adaptant à la réalité de ce
patrimoine c'est une nécessité pas
seulement de mémoire mais aussi de
cohésion
merci merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres je
vous rappelle que nos prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le
mercredi 28 juin à 15h je vais suspendre
la séance et elle sera reprise à 16h30
pour l'examen de la promotion de loi
visant à lutter contre le dumping social
sur le transmence la séance est
suspendue